Never give the opponent the impression that you have been hit.
You're going to ask me an embarrassing question,
for example,
and we're going to see how a tries to get by in those moments.
Go ahead.
Ask me the strong question.
So. Uh,
how do you plan to lower the price of
bread and raise the price of wheat for farmers.
That's fine.
So you see the machine smile.
And at the same time,
if you could hear my inner voice that you don't hear,
of course my thought is,
ah the cow.
Ah the bastard.
How do I get anything out of it?
They gave me nothing.
So then they have to get out of it.
So to get out of this,
they have to think about it and find an answer.
Only he can't stop like that you know,
he can't just stand there and say what more am I going to do?
I said so I'm waiting for your answer,
right?
Whenever you feel he is in trouble,
you harass him.
So there is a process that is very simple,
that is very easy.
These are sentences that automatically come like this.
They don't think at all about what they are saying,
do they?
They are thinking.
So it pretty much looks like this.
Mister berteau,
uh,
you asked me.
You asked me a question that I actually expected,
and I have to say that even if you hadn't asked me,
it's a problem that I probably would have addressed myself.
Because it's an extremely serious problem that
starts the lap time from an extremely serious,
extremely important relay.
And the French,
the French who listen to us,
have the right to know what it is.
Well,
that's exactly seconds.
There,
seconds you see in the.
I didn't say anything at all.
Twenty seconds, huh?
Twenty seconds.
But I practiced a lot.
So if it's not enough,
if it's not enough,
I go on,
you rope,
you close,
here we go.
Renault, he looked,
you see,
but that's enough.
So I would like,
if I may,
Mr. Bertaud,
to answer this question with infinite ease.
Indeed,
it is a question that primarily concerns the nation and
even the agricultural nation that listens to us and is worried.
And we understand his concern.
So you asked me this question very frankly and I will answer it very frankly.
How much is that?
seconds?
seconds To say nothing,
I still haven't said anything,
but at that point you'll have to end up giving me an answer from.